ich habe Hunger übrigens die Flasche
habe ich von Amazon den Link packe ich
euch in die Videobeschreibung
Schleichwerbung ist die beste
Trinkflasche seit ich diese Trinkflasche
habe trinke ich so viel Wasser ich habe
Hunger und das liegt daran dass ich
zurzeit intermitting fasting mache ich
weiß nicht ob das richtig ausgesprochen
ist ich esse 8 Stunden am Tag und 16
Stunden lang mache ich Pause und zur
Zeit mache ich das von 12 bis 8 Uhr mein
Rhythmus passt es ganz gut manchmal
stehe ich schon früh auf dann dauert es
und man hat Hunger das ist ein bisschen
ang enehm aber ansonsten funktioniert
für mich ganz wunderbar ist ein kleiner
Einblick in mein Leben
welcome ich habe übrigens noch den Senf
und Soßen Adventskalender bekommen falls
ihr den Senf und soßenadentskalender se
schreibt in die Videobeschreibung in die
Kommentare in die Videobeschreibung los
bei mir hallo kann es sein dass du dumm
bist ach jetzt weiß ich auch warum ich
euch das mit dem Fasten erzählt habe
weil Seeberger sehr gesund ist und heute
gibt den Seeberger Adventskalender wird
der langweilig das könnte sein
vielleicht auch nicht und daran halt mir
fest
der klappt sich aber hier schön auf mein
weihnachtsherz ist glücklich könnt ihr
erkennen dass hier so Sterne sind die
kann man so rausdrücken so einmal
abtrennen ein Moment wir haben gleich
die werde ich aufbewahren das ist
praktisch ich weiß auf dem ersten Blick
wirk der Seeberger advkalender
vielleicht ein bisschen langweilig aber
ich finde Seeberger so ein teures
Produkt was ich mir nie wirklich gönne
wenn ich z.B fürs Kochen oder so Nüsse
brauche dann hole ich sie halt nicht von
Seeberger und wenn ich mir Snacks von
Seeberger kaufe dann ist das mit dem
wirklichen commitment da will ich
wirklich Fitness food Queen sein und
einfach mich gesund ernähren deswegen ja
ich bin gespannt wie viel hat er denn
gekostet
25 ist der für 25 ja 25 € toller Preis
ich bin gespannt wie viel hier drin sein
wird mit einem Adventskalender für 25 €
hat man nichts falsch gemacht das ist
ein guter Preis man hat nicht
übertrieben aber man gönnt sich auch was
so fühlt sich für mich der Preis an die
Seite provoziert mich und weil ich vor
Hunger fast umfalle Nummer
ein cute sehr klein ne 15 g praktisch
ist der schon überlegt mal wenn man so
ein Kalender hat wie viel man davon
eigentlich immer essen trinken und
benutzen kann jetzt bei Beauty
kalalendern okay das benutzt man halt
länger aber wenn man so ein
snackkalender hat dann nimmst du dir das
jeden Tag mit zur Arbeit zur Schule und
hier haben wir Mandeln honigsalz okay
wie gesund kann das sein
ne so sieht das aus sehr
salzig 56 Cent ich meine dieser Kalender
hat 25 € jedes Türchen sollte ungefähr
ein Wert von Euro haben wir bei 56 Cent
ja aber die sind auch extra verpackt ne
das ist nicht einfach nur ein Produkt
reingemacht oder so das ist komm Nummer
zi kontrovers Mandeln nach Mandeln
geröstet und gesalzen so sieht eine
rauchmandel
aus WoW ich esse sehr wenig Sachen die
geräuchert sind weil ich davon meine
Kopfschmerzen zu bekommen von z.B
geräucherten Fisch und so oh mein Gott
sind die lecker die schmecken nach
Schink
50 Cent ne 47 Cent tüchen Nummer
3 die haben wahrscheinlich so viele
verschiedene Produkte da drin und Sie
entscheiden sich honigmandeln
rauchmandeln und gebrannte Mandeln
dahinterher zu machen jetzt es ist nicht
mal eine harte Kritik es ist wirklich
meine
Frage sieht die toll aus meine Damen und
Herren eine gebrannte Mandel die wird
super
schmecken die kann definitiv nicht
mithalten mit weihnachtsmarktmandeln
aber sie kann elich so mithalten die
schmeckt zwar süß aber sie hat nicht
diesen Karamell Geschmack wie auf dem
Jahrmarkt steht hier leider nein wir
sinken in unserem Preis die letzten
waren 47 Cent jetzt haben wir 46 Cent
Nummer 4 nusstrio geröstet und gesalzen
30 g
u okay nehmen uns mal so eine Mandel
hatten ja noch lange keine Mandel das
muss man bei Seeberger auch sagen die
sind zwar teurer aber wenn Sie ein Nuss
Trio haben dann ist wirklich jede Nuss
auch mit vertreten und nicht wie in den
billigeren Mischung dass da nur Erdnüsse
drin sind oder Rosin beim
Studentenfutter tolle Mischung 1,19
Nummer 5 oh pistazen also wirklich
Pistazien ist das Gold unter den
Nüssen ich habe so kindheitsflashbacks
davon ich gerne Pistazien gegessen hätte
aber wir uns die nicht leisten konnten
und für mich war Pistazien die Nüsse der
reichen Menschen falls ihr nicht wisst
wie eine Pistazie aussieht
so toll gut gesalzen und praktisch man
nur so eine kleine Packung hat dann
istst man wirklich nur ein paar 47 Cent
ach komm da hättet ihr ein paar mehr
gönnen können tche Nummer 6 und damit
Nikolaus wir rennen zu unserem Seeberger
Adventskalender ich hoffe Seeberger ist
jetzt ein deutsches Unternehmen und weiß
dass Nikolaus ist ich weiß warowski ist
kein deutsches Unternehmen gewesen ich
habe das gesagt warowski kommt aus
Österreich aber kommt safe aus
Deutschland
50 g Studentenfutter also Seeberger ich
muss euch das doch nicht erklären da
hättet ihr gebrannte Mandeln genommen
und davon 50 g ich liebe diese kleinen
Tüten es fühlt sich an als ob man
kaufmladen spielt oh was hatten wir noch
nicht eine Haselnuss tolle
studentenfuttermischung und eine
walennuss super
Snack sehr gesund bio ist für mich
Abfall das ist einfach das
Studentenfutter von rich people oh mein
Gott eigentlich sollte man das Geld
dafür ausgeben man gibt so viel Geld für
ungesunde scheiße aus ne warum nicht
auch mal dafür 16,60€ das Türchen ne das
ist doch mal wertvoll jetzt will ich
aber was Verrücktes das alles außer die
geräucherten Mandeln habe ich schon Taus
mal probiert oh 40 g
genussmix was ist denn in diesem
genussmix drin Schoko Cranberry Mix
sweet and salty und Mandel und
casews WoW sogar gar nicht so wenig weiß
nicht wie gesund jetzt eine Schoko
Cranberry ist
das ist
wirklich tolle Schokolade ich bin Fan
vom genussmix hey und das Kilopreis ist
gar nicht so teuer 96 Cent Nummer 8
davor hatte ich ein bisschen Angst dass
es kommt
Aprikosen das sind zwei Stück aber sind
20 g also was soll da noch drin sein ne
trocknete
[Musik]
Aprikose ich weiß Aprikosen sind so
beliebt aber von allen Trockenfrüchten
ma ich die wirklich am wenigsten die
fühlen sich praktisch an die fühlen sich
an wie Zutat wie etwas was man nicht nur
so essen sollte der Geschmack ist auch
nicht schmeckt nach Silvesterfeuerwerk
Böller auf der Straße der nächste Tag
alles ist so ein bisschen Dings so
schmecken Aprikose Aprikosen was kostet
ihr 47 Cent okay seberger Türchen Nummer
9 ich weiß ihr seid große mallwan Fans
und deswegen habt ihr Türchen Nummer 9
zum besten Türchen
erklärt gebrannte Kürbiskerne sugar
roasted pumpkin seeds pumpkin ist das
schönere Wort für Kürbis es schmeckt
nach hamsterstall Süßer hamsterstall ich
wer nie darauf gekommen gebrannte
Kürbiskerne zu holen aber der Geschmack
hat viel mehr Tiefe als gebrannte
Mandeln 30 Cent das billigste tüchen
Türchen Nummer 9 ich Flip aus Türchen
Nummer 10 wird dafür viel
besser da drin ist Kaki ah stimmt die
Kaki irgendwann hatte Aldi angefangen
die Kaki zu haben und ich dachte richtig
ich habe plötzlich die Welt entdeckt das
ist die kakif Frucht sieht ein bisschen
aus wie eine Tomate Kaki schmeckt sehr
lecker aber auch gewöhnungsbedürftig
hier hat man ein bisschen mehr riechen
tut schon mal sehr
gut die schmeckt zu mählig vielleicht
klein geschnitten eine Soße rein oder so
für so ein kleinen fruchtigen K 73 Cent
du die hättet ihr euch bei der Kaki
sparen können die 73 Cent pack sie wo
anders rein Nummer 11 Mandel Cranberry
Mix sehr viel Mandeln Seeberger ist
stolz auf seine Mandeln erstmal eine
Cranberry
langweilig B ohne Schokolade wie kann
man das machen oh Cranberry schmeckt ich
glaube ich mag Cranberry sehr gerne auch
ohne Schokolade schmeckt sie sehr gut
und Mandel bisschen mehr Cranberries als
Mandeln da drin 60 Cent ich muss ein
kleines climer machen weil bei manchen
z.B 150 g angeboten werden und bei
anderen z.B 50 g und dadurch wird der
Kilopreis halt auch teurer eigentlich
müsste ich fair sein und den 150 g Preis
immer machen boah krass 50 150 g
unterscheidet sich so stark es lohnt
sich überhaupt nicht die Kleinpackungen
bei Sieger zu kaufen wir machen mal die
kleinsten dann s das teuerste so
Halbzeit in unserem Kalender und uns
geht schon viel besser ich habe gar
nicht mehr so großen hungerger ist
wirklich stolz auf seine Mandel hier
haben wir salzmandeln man kann Nudeln
machen warm man kann Nudeln machen kalt
man kann Mandeln machen süß man kann
Mandeln machen
salzig gesalzene Mandeln ganz leicht und
gesalzene ich GLB die sind sogar
geröstet sind auch geröstet undes ich
weiß nicht warum da nur gesalzen draf
steht das Erich im so eine al Schokolade
mit Mandeln die wir früher mal ganz
gerne gegessen haben und ich bilde mir
ein die Schokolade mit zu schmecken 40
Cent 13 ihr dürft zuerst
gucken
nadamias Ken so ein gutes asmr Video mit
maadamias dann nimmt er die mit Stäbchen
so auf und isst die mit ein bisschen
Schokolade und so V
Australia ich weiß noch als ich das
allererste Mal in meinem Leben makadamis
gegessen habe und wirklich dachte was
können Nüsse eigentlich
nicht das maadamia Eis von hegen das so
lecker kann nicht mehr essen aber damals
war so lecker mein Körper wird sich
gleich denken what the Vanessa
Alarm Alarm das höste der Gefühle was du
manchmal gibst ist eine Mandel oder eine
Walnuss und jetzt isst du einfach jede
Nuss makadamia Nüsse sind so teuer 82
Cent 14 lässt sich aber sehr schön
Öffnen der Kalender und sieht auch nach
mehreren geöffneten Türchen schön aus
geröstete nussvielfalt ohne Salz ist
einer meiner absoluten Classics die ich
mir tatsächlich sehr oft von Seeberger
hole ich finde nämlich Nüsse schmecken
toll geröstet sind sie einfach 100 mal
besser hier haben wir auch zum ersten
Mal eine pekanuss kann nicht glauben
dass es in Amerika einen pekanuss Pie
gibt und das nur mit peganüssen voll
ist weil ich finde es ist schon eine
leckeren Nuss aber bisschen wie eine
schüterne Walnuss okay ja ist nichts los
da ist kein Salz dran ein nur geröstet
schmeckt dadurch ein bisschen besser 80
Cent gönn doch Schwester 15
paranusskerne paranusskerne sind diese
Nüsse die in jeder Nussmischung nur
dreimal drin sind da haben die alle
viele Kalorien ne ich esse hier auch
ganz schön viele Nüsse 100 g kommt
bestimmt hin 700 Kalorien also ist das
Fett meine ist gutes Fett
aber Nüsse sind gesund hallo
Paranuss ich finde Paranüsse schmecken
trocken ich hab gesagt ich hab gesagt
kleine funf zu Nüssen das ist wird auch
die amazonasmandel oder Amazonas
Kastanie genannt bisschen erdig schmeckt
sie 64 Cent ich find so komisch diese
kleinen Beträge die G aufzuschreiben 16
ich Brau mal hier wieder was
schokoladiges oh mein Gott ich glaub es
ja nicht das hat mir der liebe Gott
geschickt der schokomix der schokomix 40
g schokomix darf ich eigentlich nicht
essen ist Laktose drin aber da sind
einfach kleine schok Stücke da drin
einfach Nüsse und Schokolade ja und
ansonsten noch Cranberries ist schon so
der kleine Dessert miixx glaube ich m da
isst man halt Schokolade aber man isst
auch was gesundes man ist nicht nur
Scheiße mit peküssen seberger hier bin
ich enttäuscht ich hatte die kleinste
pekanuss der Welt steht schokomix mit
peküssen 1,18 € 17 denk mal jetzt können
wir keine Schokolade mehr erwarten wow
ich weiß nicht warum sie am Anfang so
viele Mandeln hatten jetzt kommen hier
die richtig verrückten Sachen Crunch FA
Snack kerbsen sind jetzt drin und die
favabohne das hier jetzt der kleine
Fitness Snack das ist die favbohne sagt
hallo oh mein Gott die farbohne
lecker kigaerbsen sind auch lecker so
sieht der Mix aus bisschen trocken aber
lecker aber geschmacklich könnte ich
glaube ich nicht viel davon essen 60
Cent
18 eben hatten wir nicht mal eine pekuss
und hier eine ganze Tüte
voll nice und wisst ihr was ich packe
euch die pekernüsse in die
verlosungsadventskalender denn da drin
da hinten da befindet sich der Inhalt
meiner Adventskalender Videos und am
Ende so Ende November ungefähr dann
werde ich sie verpacken und als einzelne
Adventskalender an Euch verlosen und
dafür müsst ihr mir einfach nur auf
Instagram folgen und dort werdet ihr
alle weiteren Infos dazu bekommen also
wenn es dann soweit ist ihr könnt euch
freuen auf pekernüsse boah die sind
teuer 1
€ 10
Leute 19 ja also das ist auf jeden Fall
auch wichtig gebrannte Erdnusskerne da
muss wirklich von jeder Sorte was dabei
sein hatten mir gebrannte Mandeln
gebrannte Kürbiskerne und gebrannte
Erdnüsse es ist ein Weihnachtskalender
das muss auf jeden Fall schon drin sein
uh mit Sesam so hier seht ihr sie die
sind feucht geworden die sind auf jeden
Fall nicht knusprig die sind ganz lecker
aber es ist es ist nicht gebrannt so wie
man es kennt 23 Cent wir sind in den
20ern angekommen das heißt endpurt
boring Cashew Cranberry Mix wir hatten
ja schon ein Cranberry Mix aber den
packe ich euch da rein weil Cranberries
und Cashews habe ich eben genug gegessen
38 Cent 21 Walnüsse tiptop ganz ehrlich
die Dinger sind so gesund ist ein
bisschen boring aber gut 90 Cent das war
schon 21 die 20er gehen doch immer so
schnell rum true sorry ich bin jetzt 30
meine 20er ging sehr schnell rum du bist
alt 22 oh Lüge die esse ich am
allerliebsten die gerösteten Mandeln
ohne Salz die schmecken wirklich finde
ich immer wie so ein Dessert wenn man
das so sagen kann ja die schmecken
einfach wie ein bisschen als ob da mehr
dran ist als einfach nur eine Mandel und
ich weiß nicht warum mir gefällt aber
diese blaue Verpackung von Seeberger mir
gefällt das einfach gut wenn die auch
blau verpackt sind ich finde das sieht
hübsch aus das ist ja so deren
klassisches Design und ich weiß nicht
ich mag das total gern pack ich euch in
die verlosungsbox 40 Cent vorletztes
Türchen wir sind so Sund durch diesen
Dezember gekommen tolle Nährstoffe
Cashews geröstet und gesalzen das ist
doch toll als ob Seeberger gewusst hätte
dass ich kaum noch was schaffe haben die
jetzt nur noch so die langweiligen
Klassiker reingemacht die ich in jeder
anderen Mischung eh schon probiert habe
50 Cent Türchen 24 ich liebe es also 24
da muss jetzt was drin sein was knallt
was gut schmeckt was weihnachtlich ist
was vielleicht lebkugen hat ja warum
nicht kakaomandeln dieser Kalender ist
einfach ein mandelkalender und sie
mussten noch so ein bisschen was anderes
reinpacken kakaomandeln ja die werden
doch
schmecken natürlich werden die schmecken
guckt euch das doch mal ahan die sind
komplett in Schokolade
umwickelt das darf ich eigentlich nicht
oh das
verboten super 15 g hier hätte man noch
50 reinquetschen können an Weihnachten
muss man nämlich Teilen mit der ganzen
Familie und was soll ich d mit 15 g
kakaomandeln sind die eine extra
Produktion weil ich sie nicht finde ne
einfach den Preis von gebrannte Mandel
45 Cent also bevor wir den Preis jetzt
zusammenrechnen ich muss sagen es ist
toll von den Größen von diesen Päckchen
dass ich morgens mitnehmen alles super
es ist viel Plastikmüll es sind alles
kleine Plastikverpackungen aber darum
soll es mir nicht gehen Ich finde eher
die Auswahl noch ein bisschen
verbesserungswürdig ja vielleicht
vielleicht noch ein paar getrocknete
Früchte ich verstehe halt nicht warum
Aprikose und Kaki ausgesucht wurde finde
Mango besser Mango ist aber vielleicht
zu groß ich weiß jetzt aber auch nicht
wie die letzten Jahre die Kalender waren
und vielleicht wollten sie mal was
anderes machen hier sind noch mal alle
Produkte aufgelistet falls man sich
komplett spoilern lassen möchte ja aber
also zweimal Obst in 24 Türchen weiß ich
nicht dier und wenn ich alle Preise
zusammenrechne kommt raus 16 € ich habe
in den meisten Fällen vom Kilopreis von
der 150 g Packung runtergerechnet also
bei Seeberger ist das so umso größer die
Packung ist umso weniger Hal so für das
Kilo aber ich finde 9 € für Verpackung
und dass sie es in kleine Packung
abgefüllt haben schade irgendwie ich
meine man kauft doch trotzdem so viel
Seeberger Produkte ja ich die Verpackung
kostet halt was ne also das halt zu
dingsen so man kann doch als Firma dann
sagen okay dann ist dieser
Adventskalender unser Marketing am Ende
des Jahres dass man sich halt durch alle
weil am Ende probiert man sich ja auch
alle durch durch alle Produkte durch und
entdeckt vielleicht was neues von
Seeberger was man gar nicht kennt und
ist dann irgendwie toller neue Kunde für
irgendwelche Produkte dennoch finde ich
dass man ihn selbst gemacht nicht so gut
hinkriegen würde weil wenn ich jetzt
meinem Schatzi meinem Freund meiner
Freundin meinem Kind sonst wem so ein
Snack Kalender machen möchte wo ich sage
hey ich will wirklich dass das Kind Kind
so Nüsse und sowas ist
obwohl dann würde sich das halt mehr
wiederholen dann würde man z.B eine
große studentenfuttermischung holen dann
würde man kleine Säckchen vorbereiten
das ist eigentlich eine mega gute Idee
dann bereitet man kleine Säckchen vor
und dann gibt es in dem Adventskalender
jeden Tag die Snacks für den Tag also so
z.B Studentenfutter und eine Mandarine
das Problem ist nur wie lange sind
Mandarin haltbar nicht 24 Tage keine
Mandarin macht keine Mandarine in den
Kalender aber so ein Snack wisst ihr
dann dann könnt ihr da so kleine
Säckchen holen dann macht ihr geröstete
Mandeln rein oder was die Person auch
gerne ist und dann würde man auf jeden
Fall sehr viel günstiger wegkommen man
darf halt nicht übertreiben ne das darf
halt nicht zu krass sein ja also der
Warenwert ist halt 16 € wenn man von 150
g Kilopreis ausgeht aber man bekommt
halt alles in den miniaturgrößen ich
weiß nicht ob es 10 € extra zahlen cool
ist aber es ist cool bin bisschen hin
und her gerissen ich wä aber happy
gewesen wenn mir Timo den geschenkt
hätte dann würde ich mich glaube ich
jeden Morgen freuen sagt mir gerne was
ihr von dem Kalender haltet ich steck
sie in den Mund die haselnussi Pik nussi
makadamia
tschüss